thank you so much for having us this
hasn't happened for more than a decade
the Council of Europe created to protect
democracy after the second world war
holding a summit a year since Russia was
expelled
president zelenski you have the floor
there is one clear subject on the agenda
and one leader everyone wants to hear
from we are trying very hard to improve
the protection of our people and I thank
all the countries and leaders who help
us to improve our air defense
all together we are showing what our 100
men
and what the power of the Free World
means today the UK joined other
countries signing up to an International
Register of Damages recording harm
caused by Russian aggression today we
are facing the greatest threat to
democracy and the rule of law on our
continent but on the world stage
domestic politics is off is off the play
too
to cooperate across borders and across
jurisdictions to end illegal migration
and stop the boats
the council already plays a vital role
but I urge leaders to consider how we
can go further
because we know what we can achieve
together
and this is a prime minister in trouble
at home if you see that has been
weakened by a dire set of local election
results he wants to use this as an
opportunity on the world stage to send a
message that he is tough on immigration
back home he knows he is facing pressure
from the right of his party do you think
you can actually achieve something
European leaders today or is this just
rhetoric for domestic consumption well
well actually the the UK has a long
track record of leading and being at the
heart of these conversations on camera
the meetings were friendly it was lovely
coronation off camera the Prime Minister
met with the president of the European
Court of Human Rights he urged reform to
stop interventions like this one the
Rwanda flight controversially grounded
last year by a European judge but it's
not clear there's any willingness for
change elsewhere in Europe
our principles in our DNA and we want to
be more efficient to fight against
snuggles
[Music]
The Diplomatic ritual the Cozy European
lineup it all sends a message striking
the right tone over the coming days
abroad and at home where it be easy for
Rishi sinac